a quality controlled expert at a drink
bottling factory took a random sample of
bottles from a batch and measured the
amount of liquid in each bottle in the
sample
the amount in the sample had a mean of
503 milliliters and a standard deviation
of 5 milliliters they want to test if
this is convincing evidence that the
mean amount for bottles in this batch is
different than the target value of 500
milliliters
let mu be the mean amount of liquid in
each bottle in the batch
write an appropriate set of hypotheses
for their significance test for the
significance test that the quality
control expert is running
so pause this video and see if you can
do that all right now let's do this
together so first you're going to have
two hypotheses you're going to have your
null hypothesis
and your alternative hypothesis your
null hypothesis is going to be a
hypothesis about the population
parameter that you care about and it's
going to assume kind of the status quo
no news here and so the parameter that
we care about is the mean amount of
liquid in the bottles in the batch so
that's mu right over there and what
would be the assumption that that would
be the no news here
well it would be 500 milliliters that's
the target value so it's reasonable to
say well you know the null is it's doing
what it's supposed to that where the
actual mean for the batch is actually
what the target needs to be is actually
500 milliliters
some of you might have said hey wait
didn't they say the amount in the sample
had a mean of 503 milliliters why isn't
this 503
remember your hypothesis is going to be
about the population parameter your
assumption about the population
parameter this 503 milliliters right
over here this is a sample statistic
this is a sample mean that's trying to
estimate this thing right over here when
we do our significance test we're going
to incorporate this 533 milliliters
we're going to think about well what's
the probability of getting a sample
statistic a sample mean this far or
further away from the assumed mean if we
assume that the null hypothesis is true
and if that probability is below a
threshold our significance level then we
reject the null hypothesis and it would
suggest the alternative but if we're
just trying to
generate or write a set of hypotheses
this would be our null hypothesis and
then our alternative hypothesis is that
the true mean for the batch is something
different
than 500
milliliters